[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue à besançon on
est ici au coeur de la vieille ville sur
cette place de la révolution
méconnaissable transformé pour vous
faire vivre un très très bel
anniversaire il ya dix ans jour pour
jour les fortifications vauban faisaient
leur entrée à l'unesco c'est donc un
moment de fête quand vous propose de
vivre dans cette émission la grande fête
du patrimoine mondial on a soufflé les
bougies
on a sorti le gâteau 1500 par sont en
train d'être distribuées gratuitement
mais on n'est pas là pour parler
gastronomie il va y avoir du spectacle
un très beau son et lumière en fin
d'émission il y aura de la musique il à
philippe prost grand architecte qui nous
fait plaisir d'être ici avec nous nous
servir un peu de fil rouge durant cette
émission on va parler bien sûr histoire
et patrimoine avec lui si thierry
regarder elle se dirige vers la
citadelle à bord de son petit train on
la retrouve dans quelques instants et en
attendant qu'il arrive bien je vous
propose un petit retour dix ans en
arrière
même lieu même fait regarder 7 juillet
la nouvelle tombe en provenance de
québec le réseau des sites vauban
décroche son inscription au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
à besançon la population salut
l'événement lors d'un rassemblement
festif
cette inscription est le fruit d'un long
chemin semé d'embûches
il aura fallu quatre ans pour convaincre
et choisir parmi 160 sites européens
pour la première fois l'institution
labellise un réseau fort de douze
fortifications besançon mais aussi arras
briançon ou neuf-brisach 12 sites qui
ont été jugés les plus authentiques et
les plus représentatives de l'oeuvre
vauban et qui colle à la définition de
patrimoine mondial un patrimoine d'une
valeur universelle exceptionnelle
voilà patrimoine d'une valeur
universelle exceptionnelle c'est avoue
philippe callender le contraire non
assurément non ce qui fait la force de
ses raisonnements bien de voir c'est que
ce n'est pas seulement un site qui est
inscrit à l'unesco ce sont douze sites
inscrits et je crois que c'est ce qui
fait la valeur de ce classement au
patrimoine mondial
c'est à dire que c'est les 12 sites qui
permettent de rendre compte de l'oeuvre
de vauban pendant toute sa carrière sur
des sites de co hôte l'aller
l'atlantique la manche sur des sites de
montagne les pyrénées les alpes sur les
sites de plaine la plaine d'alsace la
plaine de flandre et donc toute la
diversité aussi typologique c'est à dire
une simple tour une villeneuve fortifiée
une place forte de montagne comme
briançon une ville dans la plaine
d'alsace comme neuf brisach ou une ville
et une citadelle comme besançon tout
simplement dans un méandre du doubs
avoir parlé tout à l'heure de la
citadelle mais d'abord je voudrais qu'on
comprenne qui est beau bon alors on a
tous forcément un jour ou l'autre
entendu parler de lui surtout vu ici en
bourgogne franche comté puisqu'il année
dans le morvan qui est devant vauban
c'est un personnage très particulier
parce que c'est un personnage qui va
obtenir l'oreille du roi très jeune qui
va être repérés comme le meilleur jeune
un jeune ingénieur de toute sa
génération et qui va se voir confier une
mission qui est de fortifier les
frontières du royaume et il va disposer
pour cela d'un corps d'ingénieurs et des
seuls deux soldats qui vont
l'accompagner dans cette oeuvre qui va
développer pendant plusieurs décennies
des années 767 jusqu'à sa mort en 1707
cder pendant 40 ans parmi cette oeuvre
foisonnante c'est quoi peut-être votre
coup de coeur avoue mon coup de coeur il
y en a beaucoup les coups de coeur parce
que c'est une oeuvre exceptionnelle mais
je dirais que la citadelle de besançon
est un
exceptionnel vous n'êtes plus tard plus
plaisir ben justement nous aussi
bisontin
bien sûr pour nous c'est la plus belle
oeuvre de rebond et on va justement se
diriger vers la citadelle pour retrouver
lucie thierry je crois que vous êtes
enfin arrivé ici
nous voilà devant le front royal à la
citadelle qui ouvre ses portes
gratuitement ce week-end aux visiteurs
justement on va rejoindre un groupe de
visiteurs
bonsoir chantal alors dites-nous qu'est
ce qui vous amène ici bien la beauté du
site
et puis notre ami vauban tout de même
parce que en tant que passionné du
personnage j'ai aujourd'hui on est mon
mari et ma famille qui était de passage
dans la région
originaire du limousin pour ma soeur et
mon beau-frère et puis mon fils qui lui
habite lons le saunier depuis quelques
temps vous est comblé par ce toujours
oui à chaque fois que l'on vient on est
vraiment comblé par par le site par
l'oeuvre de notre fameux personnage qui
est donc vauban alors justement
christine vauban il a façonné la
fortifier ce site
il l'a rendu imprenable et on le voit à
l'épaisseur et la hauteur de ses murs
réussi en fait sur le bastion
occidentale et donc la grande innovation
au xviie siècle s'arrête là
fortifications bastionnées que l'on voit
tout autour de nous héritée des
ingénieurs italiens qui l'ont inventée
au xvème siècle on l'a emporté ici en
france au xvème xvième siècle ont fait
les améliorations passe par les
ingénieurs hollandais et avec vauban on
va véritablement systématiser ce bastion
le bastion c'est quelque chose qui va
venir remplacer la tour médiévale et qui
va être de forme polygonale avec deux
flancs et de face2face
face à l'agresseur face à l'ennemi avec
une gorge qui rattache en fait le
bastion à la citadelle vauban doit aussi
se servir du site naturel qu'est le
monde assis tout à fait donc ici on n'a
pas la forme on pourrait dire habituel
de l'étoile mais on va avoir les lure
les remparts qui ont épuisé la forme du
rocher de l'anticlinal et donc on a une
forme plus ou moins rectangulaire
concave avec ses bastions qui sont en
réalité des sceaux libations puisqu'on
avait pas en fait
la largeur nécessaire pour construire de
véritables restions bercy et on va
quitter les pierres pour retrouver les
cartons direction la place de la
révolution
c'est vraiment important votre enfant on
va y aller doucement la structure
commence à être lourd elle a confié un
petit peu on va y aller doucement et
ensemble à 3 pour faire la pub elle le
fait qu'on m'ait jamais hockey jacques
rey
[Applaudissements]
carton plein ici place de la révolution
regarder un peu cette oeuvre
improbable elle est réalisée entièrement
en carton c'est la réplique d'un arc de
triomphe celui du combattant de besançon
ils avaient été détruits au xviiie
siècle et le voilà qui reprend vie tout
doucement sous nos yeux regardez il est
en train de s'élever dans les airs les
passants qui sont venus participer à sa
construction sont en train de le
soulever à bout de bras c'est assez
impressionnant quand on se trouve juste
à côté
l'oeuvre est signée olivier grosse tête
c'est un plasticien connu dans le monde
entier justement pour ce genre de
création
on va demander justement à ces maçons
d'un jour pourquoi ils sont venus ici
bonjour bonjour madame comme si
t'appelles comment comment tu t'appelles
au pilier ophélie pourquoi tu es venu
ici eh ben on m'a dit qu'il y avait une
grosse tour en carton qui se
construisait j'y vais j'y vais quoi
rassure moi est-ce que c'est solide mais
oui c'est évident ses villes savent
alors ça fait ça pèse à peu près une
semaine 5 c'est vraiment vraiment
hallucinant le chef bâtisseur qui est en
train de coordonner tout ça se trouve
pas loin d'ici
mais je crois que je les ai perdus mais
tant pis on va lui demander à l'autre
madame bonjour vous êtes là depuis ce
matin ah oui pas trop fatigué site ça
consiste en quoi en fait d'ériger cette
arche à sa conscience a simplement un
gros con ce titulaire une large et on
met des cartons superposer à 30 après le
carton devient de plus en plus large de
monte de à de la tête aux pieds en
plastique elle est là je les retrouvais
lionel pudil bonjour je vous interromps
de secondes pas trop stressé là quand ça
soulève comme ça non ça va ça va c'est
pas encore le pire rassurez moi c'est
solide non c'est très solide campus le
carton c'est pas traître
si ça vient à tomber ça va doucement
vraiment doucement
le principe c'est que c'est une oeuvre
participative l'art aujourd'hui faut pas
le faire tout seul dans son coin
l'union fait la force en euros
exactement ensemble on peut changer les
choses
ensemble on peut construire avec du
papier du carton du scotch on peut
montrer que ensemble en s'amusant
on peut faire les choses on peut changer
les choses alors l'autre grand principe
de cette oeuvre
c'est que cet éphémère ça va être
détruit pourquoi détruire ce carton à ce
qui est un message politique derrière il
peut y avoir un message politique
c'est à chacun de le voir moi ça me
plaît de le dire ça me plaît de le faire
ensemble on peut construire mais
ensemble on peut détruire
après il ya aussi une notion de c'est
comme un peu comme un lego comme un
playmobil quand les minots en joue on a
construit son petit milieu sont petits
ils ont petit truc et puis après que son
fait on casse pour reconstruire autre
chose l'histoire c'est vraiment ça on
casse pour aller vers ailleurs pour
reconnaître très bien le plaisir d'être
à la merci beaucoup
lionel 1 le plaisir de détruire et bien
lui en tout cas avait le plaisir de
construire je veux bien sûr parler de
vauban regardez
voilà maintenant sur le méandre du doubs
au fil de l'eau on va pouvoir se rendre
compte à quel point vauban a marqué la
ville de son empreinte et on vous
retrouve philippe prost d'abord derrière
nous on voit cette citadelle et ses
remparts on voit très bien surtout le
rapport que vauban réussi à créer avec
la géologie c'est à dire le relief dont
on voit le plissement et comment il a
installé de manière très horizontale sur
ce relief sa citadelle avec un système
de fortification qui joue de la nature
qu'il trouve présente et de l'art de
l'artificiel c'est-à-dire de l'archi de
son architecture et on tourne la tête et
on va passer de vendée tour bastionnée
free tour bastionnée elles ont quoi de
particuliers elles font partie de ce
système défensif global oui elles ont
quelque chose de très particulier c'est
qu'elle montre le pragmatisme de vauban
vous savez dans le système bastionnée ce
qui compte c'est de pouvoir croiser les
tirs et que tout l'espace vue puisse
être défendu le bastion c'est l'idée
qu'on travaille des fortifications
horizontal et vauban comme si il est
dominé par des auteurs et décide de
construire des bastions mais sous forme
de tour ce qui est une sorte de retour à
une architecture qui était l'
architecture médiévale qui procédait
avec des systèmes de fortifications
verticale c'est très important de
comprendre cela parce que vauban est
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de système c'est
quelqu'un qui inventent qui travaille
avec le site qu'il trouve préexistants
et qui travaille aussi avec les
fortifications préexistantes
ici en l'occurrence ce n'est pas le cas
mais il joue de l'archaïsme et la
modernité il joue du système médiéval
qui traque des tours avec le système
bastionnée qu'est le système à la
moderne c'est-à-dire avec un plan
pentagonale et c'est vraiment ici qui
commencent à ériger ces tours à besançon
pourquoi à cette époque sous louis xiv
et bien parce que ici vous le voyez dans
la situation géographique où on se
trouve vous voyez qu ici on est plat que
tout de suite ça remonte et il veut être
en capacité de pouvoir défendre et
attaquer tiré sur la rive d'en face et
ne pas être bombardées par ceux qui sont
venus de côté donc plus tard d'ailleurs
on va construire d'autres certifications
sur les hauteurs mais dans un premier
temps vauban met en place un système
cohérent et continue avec la citadelle
qui se trouve derrière nous
l'enceinte urbaine qui fait tout le tour
de la ville etc et ponctuée de ces tour
bastionnée de manière à résister à des
tirs et à pouvoir s'opposer à
l'adversaire qui pourrait être sur les
hauteurs toujours dans la continuité
le seul avantage que trouvait pour
vauban à besançon cesser le doubs où
nous sommes justement oui et c'était le
principe même mais qui là est bien
antérieure à lui puisque déjà à l'époque
gauloise la ville s'installe dans cette
semaine parce que il ya une défense
naturelle qui est formé par la rivière
donc cette rivière elle est évidemment
le la première chose que donne la nature
pourra permettre de défendre le site
alors justement on va retrouver c'est
tour mais de l'intérieur tout à l'heure
nous on va profiter a encore un petit
peu de la balade
[Musique]
je sais pas si l'ambiance résonne
jusqu'aux portes bastionnée de chammard
en tout cas ça fait sacrément réchauffer
ici sur la place de la révolution de
besançon à l'occasion des 10 ans de
l'inscription à l'unesco du patrimoine
roman on est ici devant un concert
exceptionnel de la chanteuse échos qu'on
a connu demi finaliste dans ce vol sera
gardée il ya beaucoup de monde autour de
moi je suis au milieu de la foule on va
demander aux gens ce qu'ils en pensent
monsieur bonjour comment vous appelez
québec
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ces
concerts c'est une habitude d'aller
couvrir lés trois vidéos sur youtube
ça paraît incroyable parce que neuf et
là que saison et la cam une expérience
assez hallucinante surface ça y est pas
c'est bien car et en avant des groupes
venant sont des moubarak plus long terme
parce que les causes justement c'est un
peu l'égérie des bisontines et des franc
comtois et les bourguignons et les
français et de la terre entière
elle n'a que 16 ans et elle joue ce soir
avec les nets une carte est la meilleure
chose c'est de les écouter on écoute
j'ai vu danser des ombres par millet été
là pour moi je ne savais pas pour
utiliser mon enfant comme le séant il
est facile de s'y noyer
[Musique]
là
mais
[Musique]
j'ai vu tuer des hommes sans pitié du
fou est cent fois je ne savais pas
prendre
[Musique]
non
ce pas
[Musique]
à moi
m
je t'aimerai mai
[Musique]
non
mme
la ville de besançon a investi et
continue d'investir dans vauban comme
ici la tour de la pelote
elle a été ravagé par un incendie en
2013 il a fallu totalement la restaurer
et ça a coûté plus d'un million d'euros
à la collectivité
alors peut-être le plus gros travail
marie laure bassi a été de restaurer ces
de charpente exceptionnel oui cette
charte fait exceptionnel puisque celle
qui a brûlé était celle du xviie siècle
de l'époque de vauban
donc il s'agissait de lard faire de
l'art et faire à l'identique avec des
savoir faire traditionnels et essayer de
retrouver cette charpente la plus proche
possible de l'existante de celles d'in
avait disparu il faut dire qu'ici il
n'ya aucun clou aucun clou ya environ
850 pièces de bois
aucun élément métallique pas de clous
pas d'éléments qu'on pourrait trouver
dans nos charpente actuel et que des
assemblages de bois comme ça se faisait
d'ailleurs à l'époque de vauban
il faut dire que cette tour elle
existait avant vauban c'était une tour
du xvème siècle oui c'est tour
appartenait aux défenses de la ville de
la fin du xvème siècle elles
protégeaient avec une enceinte et
d'autres tours tout le quartier battant
et quand vauban réaménage toutes les
fortifications
il ré il se réapproprie cette tour il la
récupère et il la modifie par petites
touches pour qu'elle corresponde aux
besoins de l'époque et ce qui est génial
c'est qu'on peut la visiter même de
l'extérieur voilà on ne peut pas la
visiter
avec beaucoup de personnes puisqu'il ya
des problèmes d'accessibilité mais en
revanche il ya une application numérique
qui a été mise en place il ya quelques
jours et le visiteur vient devant la
tour se connecte au wifi dédié tour de
la pelote et il va pouvoir visiter tous
les niveaux de la tour virtuel
voilà comme s'il était alors on va
pousser ses murs on va sortir pour aller
maintenant direction place de la
révolution et voir ce tant attendu son
et lumière
vauban génie dans l'art de faire tomber
les défenses des villes assiégées rêve
de construire des forteresses
imprenables
sur des papiers jaunis par l'humidité
des champs-de-bataille des villes
étoiles naissent sous sa plume dans ses
cahiers des demi-lunes surgissent du sol
des tours et des remparts s'élance vers
le ciel des pierres s'unissent et
s'assemblent s'élève et 120
alors se dessine des places fortes des
citadelles et des villes nouvelles
imposante puissante majestueuse
franche comté alpes roussillon pyrénées
côte atlantique bretagne normandie
artois flandres lorraine alsace rhénanie
la marque de vauban ingénieurs et
architectes militaire s'affiche partout
or voilà pour cet extrait forcément
partielle parcellaire pas facile
philippe de résumer la vie debout
pendant quelques minutes
non certes ce n'est pas facile parce
c'est un homme qui a une vie énorme qui
se déplace sans cesse qui pendant plus
de quarante ans va sillonner la france
est avec des activités de très très très
diverses
aujourd'hui pour être à la fois un
ingénieur un architecte un urbaniste un
paysagiste un économiste un politique un
théoricien donc c'est quelqu'un qui a
une activité immense et un humaniste on
a dit de lui qu'il a fait ces
constructions pour épargner la vie de
ces hommes c'est vrai oui c'est vrai ils
cherchent à économiser la vie de ces
hommes d'abord parce qu'il sait que
former un bon soldat ça prend dix ans et
pour cela il théorise l'art du siège
mais on pourrait aussi citer l'épisode
de la révocation des lignes nantes où il
est là une des seule personne qui dit au
roi de france que c'est une erreur
terrible que de révoquer les dites les
villes a révoqué l'édit de nantes
on dit de lui aussi qu'une villes qu'il
assiège a forcément perdu et qui
neuville défendu par lui est imprenable
c'est vrai également puisque les 48
sièges qu'il mène son siège victorieux
par contre aucune ville n'est imprenable
et il leur est il le répète souvent
par contre il peut donner du temps à la
diplomatie retarder le moment de la
prise de la place forte
alors vous êtes architecte vous avez
participé à la rénovation si je peux
dire de la citadelle d'arras
est-ce que vauban encore de nos jours
exercer une influence en architecture ou
bien c'est un homme qui appartient à son
siècle au passé oui pour moi il a une
influence énorme d'abord dans mon
travail mais aussi plus généralement
parce c'est un des premiers à réfléchir
à l'économie des ressources naturelles
la pénurie la recherche de recueillir
l'eau de pluie de la stocker de la
filtrer de pouvoir la rendre consommable
la recherche de l'économie des moyens
pour la construction il cherche toujours
à rationaliser la construction pour
dépenser moins d'argent et pour
construire des architectures pérenne et
je crois qu'on a devant nous le
témoignage s'architecture pérenne
puisqu'elles sont toujours debout
plusieurs siècles plus tard c'est vrai
j'ai peut-être pour terminer vous posez
une colle si vous deviez résumer vauban
trois mots ce serait quoi et ses trois
mois alors je dirais
l'intelligence du contexte là j'ai déjà
dit deux mots ça fait déjà trois autres
l'intelligence l'intelligence qui le
caractérise l'humanité sans doute
et puis la vérité une ville partage
cette île à cette ambition de vérité qui
est très forte pour son époque et bien
ce seront les trois mots et un peu plus
de la fin merci beaucoup feliz traces
d'avoir été avec nous nous avons
accompagné durant cette émission
consacrée donc aux 10 ans de
l'inscription à l'unesco des
fortifications vauban
merci à vous merci évidemment à tous
infiniment pour votre fidélité sur
france 3 bourgogne et france 3 franche
comté et merci à toutes les équipes
techniques sans qui rien ne serait
possible merci à isabelle brunet rieuse
pour tous ces conseils pour ses
connaissances encyclopédiques
merci à vous si thierry ma part si
parfois les parents tout ce temps et je
laisse le mot de la fin merci adrien
gavazzi et on se quitte sur ces images
les images de ce magnifique son et
lumière vauban la paix des étoiles qui a
été projeté en simultané à neuf-brisach
et briançon et qui sera disponible en
est à gré en intégralité sur notre site
internet
notre page facebook et youtube tout
comme cette émission coup il nous reste
à vous souhaiter une excellente soirée
ou suite à des les places fortes qu'à
nos plaines inondables et patrie
nul homme n'a davantage que lui marque
est le seul de sa batterie
[Musique]